judge Shadid I hate to do this but when
the president the United States walked
and this is your sir how are you I'm
very you're not even tired are you I'm
not that tired I'm excited because we
had an incredible day today in Ohio we
had an incredible time in Indiana and
now we're with you you left nothing on
the field 11 stops 11 cities you know I
feel very guilty about interrupting
judge Geneva I don't like doing that
she'll give you an earful about it
probably soon the closing arguments seem
to be the same I just started my show
tonight and I said this is where we were
two years ago this is the record of
Obama yeah by the way the biggest joke I
saw this weekend it's him saying a guy
that said you didn't build that I
started this and oh my god it's an
oculus it is and frankly if their agenda
kept going forward meaning if the other
side had won we would have been down 4.2
or 6 or 7 we were going down it was very
bad when I took it over and if we didn't
open it up and cut regulations the whole
Obama thing would have collapsed it
would have been a disaster
4.5 million jobs in less than two years
4.3 million Americans off of food stamps
4 million Americans out of poverty a
path towards energy independence you
spent three-and-a-half billion on the
border wall and I know you're
disappointed you want the rest well I
want to build it over one time and you
need it and you see it but now we have
the the incredible military forces out
there and they're putting up barbed wire
fences we have a barbed wire wall and
you see that what they're doing highest
level and we are making it very strong
we're making it very intermittent our
wire plus we have a lot of digging going
on a lot of trenching and people aren't
going to come into our country without
going through the legal process you
can't do that otherwise you have we want
you to come just come legally the whole
plan of the Democrats
I guess seven hundred billion seven
hundred billion for the military the
next year I got 716 we've totally
rebuilt our military but they fight like
you've never seen to make sure we don't
build a wall and I've got one point six
billion another 1.6 billion and the
third 1.6 billion I'm building it in
nice large pieces but I'd like to build
it all at one time
their whole plan is to
and make sure that we don't build the
wall that's the whole thing
the number is peanuts compared to what
we did with a $70,000 per illegal
immigrant in this country that we pay
you know that's no lose a hundred
billion dollars a year on illegal
immigration we lose that in one year
have you spent the money to build the
wall it's just a tiny fraction of one
year we're gonna build it but that
that's not we are very strong now we
have the worst laws anywhere in the
country catch and release Visa Lottery
all of these laws are a disaster
we have the worst laws we've got to get
them changed the Democrats won't give us
any votes we need Democrat votes you
can't we don't have enough Republicans
or unless we elect a lot of Republicans
tomorrow but I will say that we're doing
really well on illegal immigration
considering we have the worst laws
you've ever seen we're moving thousands
of ms-13 out of the country they're
being put into jails and they're being
sent out of the country and frankly in a
lot of ways I like out of the country
for more because putting them into jail
let them solve it but we've moved
thousands of ms-13 gang members we moved
them out of the country we have close
races in Florida you and down out of
watching the last night in Florida
Indiana you take the libertarian out
John Donnelly loses by ten Montana now
you have the Republican Rosendale up by
three yeah you have in this state Josh
Holley up by three you have in Nevada
teen hell are holding on by three or
four yeah Arizona I don't know how a
woman that supports you know Americans
fighting with the Taliban even gets five
percent of the vote but it's apparently
a little tight race with martha mcsalley
award
I think Martha's great she is a hero she
flies he's one of the best fighter
pilots I mean she was really good I
spoke to some of the people that went
with her and were with her say said she
was tremendous as a pilot I don't know
how she could possibly lose the other
one with that she's just terrible yeah
and you talk about water walls the other
one doesn't want any water war she
doesn't want any protection nothing but
I think Martha's gonna do well and I
think North Dakota's gonna do well
Florida is a very very close race and
it's inconceivable because so it wasn't
that close for you though you did okay
we did great but
Nelson is a terrible senator you've
never be denied you said I've never
talked to him once he's never once
called me saying can I have something
for the people of Florida never once two
years almost two years whereas I must
say Rick Scott that's all he does his
call rose up as Lee wants leaves things
look at the great job he did with the
Hurricanes I mean he did a fantastic job
Lake Okeechobee they had a big problem
he's taking care of Lake Okeechobee but
Bill Nelson the current senator never
called so hopefully for the good of the
people of Florida and also I have to say
Ron DeSantis has to be governor you
can't let a man that ran Tallahassee
into the ground highest murder rate
they've ever had
corrupt crime ridden it's a desert you
can't let him be the governor of Florida
that would be a disaster run to Santa's
harvard-yale good guy hard worker I
think he's going to be a great governor
but it's a very close race you want to
make a closing argument you know it's
interesting because I watched the the
media they're trying to define this as
there's a trump midterm they kind of
forgot that unless we win still go well
then they'll go to Russia and they'll go
back to Russia go back to Russia it was
funny
Bill Clinton lost about 54 seats in the
house Obama lost 60 some-odd seats in
the house I love how Nate Silver who
said you had a 20% chance of winning on
the day of the election you know
predicting 85% chance but then you read
the article says well there could be
anywhere between 15 and 60 I could
predict 15 and 60 I don't have to do any
you know polls to find that out so it's
a it's the American people that decided
it's getting out in midterms there is
something going on those young I leave
Ohio thousands and thousands of people
can't get into this massive arena
I just left Indiana thousands and
thousands of people outside can't get
there's something going on there's an
electricity that feels like 2016 mr.
president I on the way in here it was
pouring all day here for hours I went
out for an hour I'm actually sweating
more than I like almost like Marco Rubio
that day and I like Marco don't
misunderstand me but I went out there an
hour before the show and
the crowd is electric every hat I signed
it wasn't a Hannity hat I wish I had to
die a penny for every one of the make
America great hats i signed today but
every hat was soaking wet there's a
bigger crowd outside then there is
inside true what do you want to say to
the Americans we have about 30 more
seconds if I write on the tip well I'm
just okay
I'm just honored because no matter where
I go it's the same way it's not like
just in Ohio or just in Indiana or just
right here in Missouri I'm so honored by
it there's something going on and it
reminds me of two years ago when I knew
something was going on and you know it
by the way and people that were with us
do it they were looking at each other I
remember I'll never forget to sort of
anti reporters were looking at each
other as I was making a speech with
32,000 people they were going well look
that was a great time and I think this
is going to be a great time Election Day
I actually called you I said you're
gonna get bad news about 5:30 and the
5:15 that afternoon you lost Florida
North Carolina Pennsylvania Michigan and
Wisconsin and you won them all Falls
don't mean anything do this tomorrow
lost him based on the fake news fake
news but about two hours later when they
counted the actual votes we won very
easily the home of Rush Limbaugh oh yeah
quick and Cape Girardeau is his hometown
America for you mr. president good luck
thank you put it on he left it all on
the field he did and I think monologue
tonight I did know I saw it on the plane
actually I saw it on the file you never
miss your opening monologue yeah I would
never do that mr. president thank you
thank you thank you for chefs we
appreciate it all right we're out of
time let not your heart be troubled news
continues Laura Ingraham is standing by
Laura how are you we want to say hi to
the president hi mr. president are you
gonna you gonna close this oh wow you're
doing you are doing some job you're
doing great proud of her he's laughing
and why do you always get the
compliments all the time you got the
interview last week you get the
compliment I God and you know Here I am
I don't know who's more competitive you
or the president it's a tie okay
competitive oh my gosh you guys will say
this I I think everybody's met their
match I don't think anyone has you
energy level you love this you really
love this well I love what we're doing
for the country I love what we're doing
for the people it's turned around we're
rebuilding our military our vets now
have veterans choice which they've never
had 44 years they were trying to get it
we're just doing a good job and we have
the strongest economy we've ever had in
the history of our country and win over
every record one question you want me to
ask the president on your behalf Laura
go ahead mr. president the American
people are I think desperate for calm
and unity what message tonight are you
going to give to them as we move forward
looking to the horizon of the future in
this country American people looking for
calm and unity
this is the divided country in many ways
what message do you have for America
well I think success will do that I
think we have to get over this election
see how it comes out it'll be an
interesting time but I think and I
really think we have to do that first I
think success is going to do we're
having the most successful time
financially economically that we've ever
had
I think that's gonna bring a lot of
people together it's going to start okay
mr. president thank you thank you very
much have a great show it's great to see
it Missouri my final word to everybody
is go vote right answer shock the world
again just imagine the payoff when you
look at the media's face tomorrow oh
they'll crack up it'll be that will be
worth the price of admission have a
great Hannity great show thanks so much